A Mother's Love is put to the ultimate
test to Pride's
battle as an aging King Reveals His
master plan
Geto Ries his own
forces to strike while the tyrants are
in
[Music]
turmoil and take back the Savage
Kingdom
[Music]
pra's work is never
done
her daughter is always
[Music]
hungry she's built her Legacy on the
backs of
Impala
but now she sets her sight
slower much
slower Po's health is
failing one measly mongus is barely
worth the
[Music]
energy but the Aging mother won't even
eat a
bite everything now goes to her
daughter
[Music]
maidi is just 10 months
old she still knows nothing of what it
takes to
[Music]
survive Pula has many more lessons to
teach
[Music]
but she's running out of time to prepare
her daughter for the real
world the kingdom suffers under rotten
rule
[Music]
Commander mutzi still clings to
power for her daughter ledi life is
easy she is borne into
privilege
entitled to all she ever
needs as it's never quite
enough
[Music]
aedi insists the whole clan bow to
her believing she deserves all the
riches
the princess Lords her rank over the
lowborns give her an inch and she'll
take a
[Music]
foot but ledi Treads a dangerous line
blood is beginning to
[Music]
boil her abuse of privilege goes too
far life at the top will be
lonely
exiled by the hyena forces the queens of
the western Pride Patrol the
outlands their cubs haven't eaten in
days
rohart their socalled King is nowhere to
be
seen a
gift a family
favorite
they all need
[Music]
this
the herd is too much to take
on but their Hasty Retreat leaves behind
a
newborn
[Music]
this is our
privilege not your lucky
day
you
even a meager Feast is worth fighting
[Music]
for and they are not the only hungry
ones a ravenous Nomad sees an e easy
meal the Queens will not give up their
price no matter who stands in their
way taking these Queens for a soft
target is a
mistake a big
mistake
the Western Pride will protect their
food and their family to the
death
no second rate Drifter is going to
replace their absent
King
Pula has all but given
up her weakness makes her and her cub
vulnerable
[Music]
where she used to stand and
fight she can now only run and
hide she's afraid of every
shadow
[Music]
out
she's barely able to care for
[Music]
herself let alone her
daughter
[Music]
Pula faces the hardest decision of her
life are you better off without
[Music]
me
for mid's
sake Pula leaves her precious
daughter
forever
family is
everything under kito's rule the makulu
pack is
[Music]
thriving the dogs are busy building
their own Dynasty on the outskirts of
the
[Music]
Kingdom eight new
pups they are the Pack's future
[Music]
hidden away beyond the Hyena's reach
until they are ready
[Music]
they will learn soon enough life is not
always
fun violent vagrants are on the Rampage
get to The
Den
[Music]
now
safely underground the pups wait out the
storm while a brave decoy draws
fire
all for one and one for
[Music]
all the pups pass their first
test follow orders and you will
[Music]
survive Unity sets the dogs
apart
the queens of the western Pride make the
most of a passing
Fortune but yet again the scent of their
success attracts
Rivals the Matata
Pride led by their Arch Enemy
sea the queens of the western
Pride are ready for a
fight their Nemesis will not take what's
theirs but the last thing they
expect is Ramo
Hara there King is
back but now he's with the
Enemy rahar returns to the Western
Pride with a whole other
[Music]
family
his double dealing secret
revealed both Prides are
his he conspires to claim all the
females and build the largest pride in
the
Kingdom
sear instructs her Cubs to join the
feast but she won't play happy
families
no one wants to
share only roh's all powerful presence
keeps a lid on the boiling
tensions the Rival Prides have no choice
but to accept this new
[Music]
Arrangement but sear has now had enough
of roh heart's
rule
[Music]
maidi has no idea she's been
abandoned she still waits for her mother
to bring back
dinner
[Music]
where are
you
[Music]
finally hunger drives her to find her
own
food
[Music]
a readed
buck she wouldn't know where to
start but
aongus this is food you know
[Music]
suddenly everything seems Out Of
Reach
mercedes's new reality comes crashing
[Music]
in
she's all alone in a big bad
[Music]
World mid's childhood is
over
[Music]
kitso leads a tactical strike Into the
Heart of the
Kingdom he knows the risks but he has a
plan
[Music]
no
wow it takes no time for the tyrants to
find
them
[Music]
to Rob them
blind The Usual Suspects take their
tax let them have
it kitso has what he came
for
he's testing the Hyena's
defenses and now knows when his new
recruits are
ready they will have the numbers to take
on
tyrants just you
[Music]
wait
every bite builds strong
[Music]
bones time to accelerate their
training
soon the 25 will fight as
one and finally break hyena
rule
Commander
mutzi is
greedy and
selfish stealing
food
from the rest of her
clan no one will find it
here
but every Tyrant has their
weakness a chip off the old
block ledi knows her own mother is
holding out on
her
what are you
[Music]
hiding LED's entitled curiosity reveals
her mother's
Secret
how dare
you mutzi can't contain her
[Music]
daughter
ledi creates
chaos she's out of
control it's all about
her take it what she wants every
[Music]
time distrust and bitterness now run
rampant the spoiled ays couldn't care
less
but mammutti knows bad blood is an
Army's
downfall
resentment is a ticking
[Applause]
[Music]
bomb
the Matata Pride will not join Ramo
harter's other
family they're better off on their
[Music]
own
sear built her house for
nothing holding on to
ridges when no one else
could she is a worthy
queen lahat wants airs as strong as
[Music]
her
but sear won't have a secondhand
[Music]
King he Treads lightly to win her
over
even playing the doting
[Music]
father but he should not get too
comfortable sear will tolerate him for
now
for the sake of the
Cubs but there will be no place for this
scheming old
man in her
Empire the makulu pack is
ready
their Fearless new soldiers are
desperate for
[Music]
Action eager to prove their
worth a lone Scout is the chance they've
been waiting
[Music]
for this is the
enemy show the Spy what you've
learned
[Music]
make him
groel
w
the dogs will dismantle their enemy one
by
one the pups have what it
[Music]
takes now is the time for Kito to lead
them into battle and end the tyrant's
bloody
[Music]
reign
Pula is fading
[Music]
fast her strength is all but
gone
[Music]
life long enemies raise the
alarm but they can see she is no longer
a
threat
with the tables
turned they will show no
[Music]
mercy please just let me
rest
but there is no peace in this wicked
[Music]
world
help
[Music]
the cruel Dawn finds Pula beaten and
broken her decision to leave saves her
daughter's
life but hers is
[Music]
done
a once great ruler of the
forest now just a
[Music]
ghost
pooler's time in this world is
[Music]
over
maidi now carries the weight of her
[Music]
Legacy a heavy burden for young
shoulders she must fight her own way
through this cruel Kingdom
if she's ever to claim her mother's
[Music]
throne